- En larmes et en colère,
c'est ainsi que l'actrice
iranienne Fatemeh Motamed-Arya
a apporté n n soutien aux
manifestants violemment
réprimandés par les forces de
l'ordre.
Elle n'est pas la seule.
Le comédien iranien Mohamed
Emrani a aussi pris position.
"Vous êtes armés, dit-il, nous
leomommes aussi, avec le sang
encore chaud de nos martyrs",
ironise-t-il dans une vidéo
diffusée sur le réseau TikTok.
SAMI AOUN, politologue,spécialiS
- Oui, la révolution est
féministe et surtout avec
ses jeunes écolières où elle a
commencé, isis elle devient
aussi une révolution épaulée
par des jeunes hommes.
(cris)
- Des jeunes qui s'en prennent
désormais aux symboles
du pouvo. . À Nishapur,
au nord-est du pays, la statue
à la gloire de l'Ayatollah
Khomeini est décapitée.
- Mais aussi, et en contre
pos,s, on voit que la machine
répressive du régime des mollahs
aussi s'intensifie et devient
de plus en plus brutale.
(cris)
- Dans cette vidéo, une femme
est frappée par des policiers
antiémeutes. Parmi eux,
defefemmes. Elle est embarquée
dans un fourgon. La scène est
diffusée par un média local.
Elle se passe à Tabriz.
PASCAL BONIFACE, géopolitologue
et directeur, IRIS
- On sait que même si le régime
est extrêmement menacé, il a
des capacités répresveves
importantes. C'est une révolte
dans la mesure où le régime
n'est pas changé, que le régime
n'est pas battu, mais le régime
peut avoir pr r parce que
c'est une révolte qui prend une
ampleur de plus en plus grande.
- Un régime qui répète,
cette fois-ci par la voix
de son président Ebrahim Raïssi,
que des forces étrangère
tentent de déstabiliser le pays.
Le président américain répond
que les Iraniennes ont
le droit de porter
ce que bon leur semb..
- L'accusation que ceux qui
protestent servent l'étranger
est une utilisation rituelle
dans tous les pouvoirs qui stt
contestés. Et évidemment,
cette jeunesse qui se révolte
n'est en rien animé par
les États-Unis ou par Israël,
mais par leur soif de liberté.
(slogan)
- Un mois de manifestations
qui ne s'essoufflent pas.
Armés de leur détermination,
les ununes continuent
de descendre dans la rue.
Au moins 23 mineurs auraient été
tués, selon ninisty Iran.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa